un fil rouge pour le père noël texte de
joëlle ecormier illustrations de flou à
fleurs chez océan jeunesse les parents
des douars ont décidé d'aller vivre dans
une île loin à l'envers du monde dans
l'autre hémisphère de l'autre côté de la
terre là où il n'ya pas d'hiver quelle
drôle d'idée en plein mois de décembre
mais noël de mont édouard inquiet ne
t'inquiète pas il y à un noël dans tous
les pays lui dit on edward m bien son
noël à lui il voudrait le mettre dans sa
valise un peu de froid du vent d'hiver
de la neige blanche un grand sapin vert
et un père noël à la barbe blanche
on ne sait jamais mais la valise
d'edouard est trop petit il peut à peine
y glisser trois mares ou quand édouard
arrive sur l'île
il ne comprend plus rien du tout il fait
chaud les arbres ont toutes leurs
feuilles et la mère a été passée au
feutre bleu lille s'appelle la réunion
c'est bien mignon mais où est passé
l'hiver on dirait que noël s'est perdu
en route
cette île est vraiment à l'envers et
noël demande encore edouard il n'y en
aura pas ce sera un noël rouge tu verras
lui dit-on rouge
mais alors ce ne sera pas vraiment un
noël noël a des habits blancs
le père noël ne sera jamais me retrouver
ici
edwards a envie de pleurer il regrette
de ne pas avoir emporté son noël à lui
dans sa valise
il sert bien forcée 3 marron dans sa
poche et doit réfléchir comment faire
pour prévenir le père noël qu'il est sur
cette île
il voudrait bien lui envoyer une lettre
pour lui expliquer mais il ne sait pas
bien écrire il pourrait lui faire un
dessin avec une carte mais il n'est pas
très fort en géographie alors edouard a
une idée plus simple puisque ici noël et
rouge est pas blanc et doivent attirer
un fil que le père noël pourra suivre
pour ne pas se perdre
un fil rouge comme ce petit jeu
à qui se verra de loin edouard hamas une
fleur rouge que la brise a fait tomber
d'un très gros flamboyant ce sera le
début de son fils tient en y regardant
de près il y a un peu de blanc là dedans
sur le fil qu'il a commencé à tirer
un cardinal s'est posée le petit oiseau
rouge se met à siffler aulas une plume
blanche cachés dessous et un volcan un
peu de lave rouge
voilà le fils d'édouard qui s'agrandit à
ça fera presque comme une cheminée tient
ce biais doigts si j'y mettais mes trois
mares on a grillé
ouille ouille ouille piment rouge le fil
bouge
chaud chaud chaud vite de lots surprises
les graines sont toutes blanches dedans
letchis rouge sucre et sucré il a le
goût du soleil chaud et mais c'est tout
blanc sous la peau attention grosse
pince rouge qui coupe le fil chaque me
i'm karine langouste rouge bizarre c'est
blanc sous la carapace paf pétain rouge
qu'elle fait
heureusement que l'oiseau ne s'est pas
envolé le fil des doigts ressemble
maintenant à une gear une grande
guirlande rouge
à force de tirer sur le fil rouge le
temps a passé
la pelote déterminé on est déjà le jour
de noël edwards est triste il ne voit
personne arrivée sur son chemin rouge et
noir fini par s'endormir
mais voilà qu'on tire sur son fil rouge
il se réveille qui a défait mon manteau
rouge dit quelqu'un et doit suis à son
tour le fil rouge pour savoir qui tire à
l'autre bout et devinez qui est la pré
du bel araucarias illuminé le père noël
comme edward ne l'a jamais vu
c'est qu'edouard à des fêtes où le
manteau rouge en tirant sur le fil
mais le père noël n'est plus en colère
il rit de toutes ses dents blanches
merci j'avais un peu chaud sous son
manteau joyeux noël edwards le père noël
lui mentent tous les cadeaux qui lui a
apporté et doit lui offrent ses trois
marron qui l'a fait griller au volcan
voilà
noël rouge et blanc cette île n'est pas
si à l'envers finalement